well the holidays should be a time to
let loose with your family and your
friends but for those battling substance
abuse it can really be a trigger for
some bad habits well john langler looks
at how families can work together to
spot trouble science
a study by one poll shows the average
american drinks double the amount of
alcohol over the holidays than any other
time of the year it can present a
challenge especially for those early in
their sobriety
considering the amount of alcohol at
holiday parties those in early sobriety
may feel uncomfortable in social
settings but addiction specialist sarah
o'brien says there are things you can do
to protect yourself or help a loved one
who is newly sober
have a support system readily available
you know through the phone whether it's
text message or a phone call someone
that's sober in recovery that you can
reach out to if things you know get
stressful o'brien also says have an exit
plan in case things become overwhelming
she suggests holding a non-alcoholic
beverage most of the time people aren't
going to ask what you want to sip on or
be tempted to give you a cocktail if
something is already in your hand and
don't feel obligated to attend an event
you know if you feel as though you can't
you know attend these parties i think
that's okay i think you know going to a
recovery based meeting or going to a
sober event you know is just as
important if not you know a lot safer
family and friends can also help by
hosting an entirely sober event or
assisting in diverting conversations to
something else and watching for clues
that someone might be struggling with
their sobriety like a change in behavior
you know from maybe a happy-go-lucky
on-time individual to someone who's
maybe not showing up for events or as
late
disheveled appearance
you know
maybe a little bit lashing out a little
bit more a little bit more irritable
discontent always remember your mental
health and your safety and sobriety is
most important if you're struggling with
addiction or mental health at any time
we have resources available at eight
newsnow dot com john langler live local
now